everyone knows Spotify is the the music
streaming service well starting today we
are launching our own Spotify music
section on Team Coco presented by AT&T
we're very tired yeah we have a lot of
fun things planned a lot of fun things
planned for the site but we're kicking
it off by posting 23 playlists
containing every musical guest we've had
on the show from 1993 until the present
this is absolutely amazing we got
let's check us out in MSE if you can
remember some of these these are some
just some of the artists who made their
late night television debut on our show
Green Day debuted on our show no doubt
Coldplay Wilco Black Keys Weezer Sheryl
Crow Arctic Monkeys ed Sheeran Queens
the Stone Age John Mayer My Morning
Jacket maroon 5 and I told everyone of
them you'll never make it
you call that music get out of here and
don't come back no it's true
all those I mean that's just great
that's just the tip of the iceberg
there's so many acts that have that have
been on our show over the years and
gotten started on our show and we
thought be really cool to do this yeah
so like 2,300 songs it is in fact here's
the entire list of the 2300 songs in
just 5 seconds check it out
[Applause]
there's like three clunkers but the rest
of them are break so go to team koco.com
Spotify check it out I think that's
going to be kind of man hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please